all right ed ed where are you from
where'd you grow up
in new york and tell me about your
family you had both your parents
growing up yes how would you describe
your childhood
good no abuse nothing
no nothing crazy no abuse
how far did you go in school
11th grade and what kind of work have
you done
um just
i'm sorry it's just um
i've done mostly self-employed work
okay like construction or
yeah stuff like that handyman stuff
and uh and so you're married you have
children
no no kids um
but you had you got convicted of a as a
sex offender yes what year was that
2010. tell me what happened
um
the i had
child pornography on
a computer and
they looked at the old or the
file share programs
limewire and and
they did a uh a sting
of the people that
that were on that and they found that
you were
watching child pornography they saw that
i had files
how did they make you aware of of this i
mean
they came to your house they came to the
house and
uh and served with a warrant
how did that happen they
came early in the morning and
basically just announce
themselves and
serve the warrant must have been a big
surprise to you
i'm sorry was that a big surprise to you
yes it was a surprise
yeah how much prison time did you
did you do that i was in uh
six months six years in prison
six years six six and a half years
and after you got out this follows you
the record
the conviction record of as a sex
offender is something you have to
register each
six months i have to register twice a
year
and see a probation officer once a month
right and does this affect your how does
this affect your life
are you are you you have to live in a
certain neighborhood or
yes i have the restrictions of
so many feet from the schools and
where do you think the interest in that
kind of
pornography came from was there anything
in your childhood or anything like that
that may have caused it or
i learned in a
class for sex offenders that it stemmed
from deep sense of sight
sensitizing myself from
a regular porn
oh so so by doing regular porn that
became
not decent so you needed something more
extreme
yes interesting
and how has that
arrest and that conviction affected your
life now
um it's very embarrassing
uh
when i did try to get a job one time
it was hard
um
but on the average
people don't know what
i'm charged with you don't
you don't know by walking in the store
or sitting next to somebody in a
restaurant
what they did so it it
[Music]
it did affect my
group of friends that i had
did you lose some friends because of
this i lost a lot of friends over that
yeah and how did your wife take it
she was and is upset
i would be can't blame her
um she stuck by me through the whole
incarceration and she is living like she
is
on probation like i am
how's that because you've where i have
to live
oh i see so she's she's taking
punishment as well because
because of what you've done
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in all of this
um
well of course not to do anything that
is
against the law but that how much
that your things that you do
affect so many people that you don't
even think of
when you're doing something stupid yeah
and what emotion do you deal with most
are you
are you angry over this are you
embarrassed are you
anxious or depressed i am
angry at myself sometimes for
even allowing this to happen
of course i'm embarrassed
and i feel for the
people that were in the videos
now that i've learned and see
that their lives has changed because of
somebody doing that to them
what's the most painful part for you i'm
sorry what is the most painful part of
all this
for you
i would have to say
disappointing my family
are you still in contact with them or
i'm sorry are you still on good terms
with your family yes
you are
and what did you do therapy or anything
like that i did
therapy yes and was that you found that
helpful yes very good
how often would that happen uh once a
week
and it took almost
a year a little bit longer what kind of
things would you
get into with therapy
we learned about how
and why we did the things that we did
what triggers
caused you to do it
stress or um
you know some of the people in therapy
has
have had victims some did not
uh it's just it's a it's a lot of
therapy for yeah
has has all this changed your views on
pornography
i'm sorry has everything you've gone
through changed your views on
pornography
yes how so i
i just learned that i don't need it
i don't need i don't need to see it uh
that's it okay
well ed thank you so much for talking
with me okay and i wish you and your
wife the best of luck
okay thank you very much